[музика]
я скажу Так в мене планували вижити Я за
себе буду говорити Я не кажу що ми не
хотіли вижити мене планували вижити і
якби наказу припинити оборону Маріуполя
не було я точно скажу що ні командира ні
я ні більшість офіцерів і певно ще
більше солдат не здались Буффон Ми там
загинули
або була така ідея що піти в розсипну і
більшість би загинула частина би вийшла
рік тому впродовж 86 днів бійці
гарнізону Маріуполя це азовці морпіхи
прикордонники поліцейські тероборонівці
та добровольці тримали кругову оборону
міста у повному оточенні з важкими боями
та відсутністю будь-якого постачання
була просто дуже багато а ну десь ми
порахували
половина всієї авіації которая котра
працювала по всій Україні рівно половина
працювала Маріуполя а потім база Сталін
в нас постійно була авіатривога або
загроза масованного авіаційного обстрілу
це коли 14 літаків летить за раз і коли
закінчилось просто поверхи Тобто там
було наприклад п'ять поверхів на
бункерми вони закінчилося а авіація
працювала працювала працювала от тоді
під кінець в нас були великі втрати від
авіації будинки буквально складалися на
очах російська авіація обстрілювала
Маріуполь та зосталь 500 кг і двотонними
авіабомбами постійно працювала артилерія
айтанки танками Вони вижигали все
взагалі абсолютно в мене навіть хлопці
підходили казали ну ми не знаємо якими
снарядами вони працюють Але там працює
будівля згорає повністю тобто
і
тактика використання танков з танків
звичайна просто заїжджає а вони
заїжджають і знищують повністю будівлю
починаючи з верхніх поверхів і отак от
складають складають
натомість начало абсолютно його людей
боєприпасів в артилерії та навіть їжі те
що зробили солдати в Маріуполі це над
людське Щось вони адаптувались до
неспинних боїв і це приблизно ну якщо
не знаю це не порівняння це так і було
тобто бо її йдуть там будівля біля
будівлі далі будівлю знищує авіація
артилерія танків вони переходять в іншу
будівлю і там за день вони могли змінити
там 2-3 будівлі ну це високоповерхівки
де від поверхівки от потім в них там
півгодинки поспати Ну тому що в нічний
час були інтенсивність боїв Була трішки
менша а потім вони знову воюють І от так
от на протязі 80-6 днів постійно
постійно постійно і звичайно ми бачили
як солдати
себе відчувають як вони воюють вони
стали знаєте от
такими роботами в голові от вони просто
в них
була одна задача - це знищити ворога
вижити зберегти особовий склад та
здаватися ніхто не збирався вони
продовжували оборону хоч ворог намагався
їх знищити 24 на 7 тоді весь світ
сколихнули фото поранених на азовсталі з
ампутаціями рук ніг та важкими ранами а
в одному з бункерів працював унікальний
військовий госпіталь де одну з
вентиляційних шахт переобладнали під
операційну нас функціонально були дві
спроможні дві хірургічні бригади можна
так сказати тобто коли працювати на два
стола
враховуючи кількість хірургів
анестезіологів завдяки
завдяки хлопцям з
Медиком яке було назовсталі які взяли з
собою
апаратуру
кисневі концентратори в нас були
повноцінні два апарата швл два
слідкуючих мені проводити з яких
кисневі концентратори Олександр
військовий лікар-анестезіолог він не був
у Маріуполі коли почалося повномасштабне
вторгнення А на Азовсталь потрапив вже
31 березня під час спеціальної місії
коли кілька медиків вилетіли з державна
гелікоптерів в оточений Маріуполь
змінювати світ Почни змінювати його з
себе через це чому чому Хтось має це
робити Тим паче також склалося що якби
на площі морально був Я готовий і
Маріуполь Мені достатньо близький був
Тому що пов'язувалось достатньо
кількість мого життя років і
нам було запропоновано що буде такий
варіант на добровільній основі
можливість для надання для допомоги
нашим хлопцям нашому шпиталю
безпосередньо в який був вже в оточенні
в Маріуполі вся територія Азов сталі
просто просто горіла як в фільмах
про якихось драконів Скажем так Напевно
що тобто ну тобто Мозги розуміли що
відбувається а очі ну тобто таке
там у підземному бункері команда лікарів
проводила важкі хірургічні операції з
повним анестезіологічним супроводом
серцево-легеневої реанімацією і
переливанням крові саме більше що я
пам'ятаю Це найбільше 30 годин не
виходило це під час прориву
14-15 квітня
тому що велика кількість було поранених
свіжих І от більше 30 годин ми не
виходили за операцією
на свої і це все паралельно під 24/7
обстрілом з усього що можливо тому що
інколи коли поряд лягали такі достатньо
серйозні то вже вибухові Скажем так були
прильоти то наші бункер це достатньо
така велика відносно площу і он дійсно
очолив у морі хитався
а так Зазвичай ну
достатньо багато ми зробили оперативне
втручань їх Напевно що ж ну ніхто не
рахував але ну Я впевнений що з таких
серйозних це більше 400 таких які
потребували
Можливо там якихось по Типу лапаротомія
ампутації таких достатньо серйозних
хірургічних обробок
тренувань і тому подібне медичні засоби
закінчувалися проте лікарі робили все
можливе для того щоб врятувати
військових у тих умовах і робили це до
тих пір поки вище військове керівництво
не дало наказу гарнізону Маріуполя
припинити оборону щоб зберегти життя
військового складу початок потрапляти
травня коли ви були евакуйовані
потрапили до полону самі тяжкі наші
реанімаційні хворі які дійсно були дуже
критичні і
якесь замилення в їхньому лікуванні Це
було б Напевно що немоча їхня смерть
тому що якби її дійсно медикаменти то
вже на той час на травень місяць
закінчувалися антибіотики знеболюючі
на апаратура не було води їсти тобто ну
якби так а потім Я особисто виходив
17-го ми б таке рішення взагалі не
прийняли якби в нас забрали поранених Це
точно А от коли ти бачиш що твій
побратим ганає лежить там без ноги в
нього там вже пішла ці всі процеси без
зворотні і йому треба медичну допомогу
тобто він повільно помирає і це не так
повільно що Годину дві день це місяць
може просто Помирати Тоді за зовсталі
Вийшло майже дві з половиною тисячі
українських військових Усі вони
потрапили в російський полон де
перебували в жахливих умовах воду
привозили нам
пожежною машиною
тому що вона дуже тянула дитиною
трьохразового харчування
дуже швидко це все прийом їжі відбувався
тобто вони по секундам засікали
дуже довго У нас кормили спеціально
кип'ятком ну тобто вона дуже гаряча була
от що з'їв то твоє єдине що знову ж таки
кодування відбувається
в основному це
током б'ють
там і голки це стандартно Я не знаю І от
те що я побачив і те що мені не
сподобалось це
стосовно татуювання це от буквально в
останніх двох обмінах було вони змушують
або ногтями
зтирати ну частково так знаєте ранки
залишаються І от мені сказали Я особисто
не бачив мені сказав що одними бійцю
змусили
якось татуювання які підком і змусили
його розтирати теж рукою
спочатку повномас вторгнення а сама
жінка з їхнім тримісячним сином 65 днів
провела у бункері азовсталі Це була
дійсно жахливо і перебування був такий
собі виклик долі особливо для мене не
тільки як для цивільна людина але й як
для мами я можу сказати що це було
дійсно таке сталеве материнство ми були
в декількох бункерах останні бункер і
основне місце в якому ми були там було з
кінця п'ять людей А 17 з цих ідей до
дітьми
мій малюк був наймолодшим не тільки в
цьому бункері але і взагалі на rockstars
обстріли на жаль не вщухали майже
постійно тобто у нас накривали або
оскараблів коктерів або з літаків або із
градів у бункері було дуже холодно не
вистачало їжі а в самої Ганни від стре
пропало молоко
для того щоб роботи суміш треба було
гріти воду на свічці або була саморобна
пічка але до того щоб її використовувати
треба було під обстрілами іти до цієї
пічки на вулиці та там нагрівати воду
ми намагалися зробити якнайкраще щоб
діти не дуже розуміли що щоб взагалі
коїться Але звичайно діти які були
постарші наприклад яким вже 10 рочків
вони вже розуміли І я думаю що Ну
звичайно будуть якісь втоми по цьому теж
ось романтичного
розладу вони моделювали їжу тому що
звичайно була нестача їжі їм хотілося
чогось солодкого фруктів І ми завжди
говорили про те що вони захочуть з'їсти
або що вони захочуть купити собі на день
народження когось якось полегшити їхнє
перебуванням
це схоже на такий якийсь
жахливий соціальний експеримент і в
таких в такій ситуації кожна людина вона
стресує вона знаходиться на грані життя
і смерті на поверхні цивільні з дітьми
змогли вибратися лише 30 квітня
українські військові відвезли їх на
маріупольську набережну і звідки їх
забрали представники ООН та Червоного
Хреста а в автобусах чекали російські
військові Після цього їх повезли у
фільтраційний табір
в нас резиновими перчатками які не
змінювалися Взагалі вони шукали якісь
націоналістичні символи
в мене вони в мене була датування
французькою мовою Lady eBay Життя
прекрасне і вони думали що це німецька
довелося їм доводити що це не так потім
нас допитували ФСБ наші показання
записували це Була доволі тяжка емоційна
бесіда тому що у міграційному таборі
вони вже знали що я дружина азовців де
перебуває зараз її чоловік Ганна не знає
Росія не виконує Женевський конвенції і
надає змоги рідним зв'язатися з
військовополоненими чи хоча б дізнатися
в якому вони стані тому жінка робить все
можливе щоб світ дізнався про оборонців
Маріуполя виступає у конгресі США ООН та
навіть їздила на зустріч до Папи
Римського мабуть останній раз ми бачили
з нею в березні на початку а потім на
жаль не був поранений і це був останній
раз коли є фізичні його бачила
а далі вже в кінці
травнях кінці травня 18 травня це було
як бачила відео на одному з
пропагандистських каналів
Він виходить на милицях поранений у
Полонному сину зараз півтора року на
жаль він не впізнає зараз тому що він
дуже маленьким я його бачив Останній раз
останній раз він бачив свого тата коли
йому було лише три місяці
тому він навіть не розуміє Як це взагалі
в якому в нього є і тато і мама у
російському полоні досі перебуває понад
1900 захисників та захисниць азовсталії
з яких понад 700 азовці саме вони
відтягнули на себе сили росіян і дали
змогу Українській армії перегрупуватися
і дочекатися отримання більшої кількості
зброї Від заходу на той момент на
початок повномасштабного ананаступу я
можу точно сказати що більш
підготовленого підрозділу в Україні я за
свою свого буду відповідати взагалі
перед тим завходном більше
підготовленого підрозділу в Україні
формату полку Не було взагалі окрім АЗС
ну полку Азов на той момент і Це дало
змогу протриматись знову ж таки в
оточенні це з їжі відпочинку без душу Ну
там і так далі взагалі без ніяких
і
Це дало змогу це дуже велика частина
нашої майбутньої Перемоги
тому що якби не було оборони Маріуполя
якби не було Азову там
той не було оборон Маріуполя це факт я
вам даю слова ну це не 99%. це 100%,
якби Азов в Маріуполі не було обороно
Маріуполя не існувало як такого взагалі
гарнізон дав змогу втримати
подвиг і зробити все можливе щоб кожний
полонений повернувся додому